Who is Little Debbie?
The simple answer is that she’s the straw-hat-wearing,
blue-eyed little girl on the front of the
box of delicious confectioneries like Oatmeal
Creme Pies, Honey Buns and whatever Star Crunches
are.
However, that’s not all she is.
“Little Debbie” is also the Executive
Vice President of McKee Foods, the eight-decade-old
still family run company that makes all of
these treats – plus Zebra Cakes and Cosmic
Brownies.
Her real name is actually Debbie McKee-Fowler
and here’s how she became the face – and
Executive Vice President – of the company
that makes Swiss Rolls.
It was 1933 and the country was in the throes
of the Great Depression.
Nearly a quarter of the nation was unemployed
and bread lines went blocks; in short, many
were desperate, including O.D. and Ruth McKee
who had lost most of their money due to a
bank failure.
What the couple did still have, however, was
a 1928 Whippet car.
According to McKee Foods’ official history,
this was when O.D. started selling five-cent
Virginia Dare Cakes made by Becker’s Bakery
out of the back of said vehicle.
By the next year, business was good enough
that they were able to purchase a Chattanooga,
Tennessee bakery, Jack’s Cookie Company.
In what was a unique arrangement for the time,
Ruth became a full managing partner in the
business with her husband.
While O.D. traveled the state making sales
and coming up with some innovative ways to
produce new product, she baked, managed the
office and took charge of the few employees
they had.
They were, as the company’s official history
put it, “ideal business partners because
her cautious, conservative nature was the
perfect complement to his risk-taking, adventuresome
spirit.”
Years later, Jack McKee would explain that
his parents had “a unique opportunity during
the Great Depression and they took a risk.”
A few months later, the bet seemed to be paying
off with the bakery moving to a larger location
down the street.
But all wasn’t perfect.
In 1934, they took on Ruth’s father, Symon
King, as a partner.
It’s not clear why they did this, perhaps
they needed an infusion of capital or maybe
they trusted King’s business instincts.
Either way, it doesn’t appear to have been
a match made in cake heaven.
In 1936, over a business disagreement, the
company split with the couple selling their
share and moving to Charlotte, North Carolina
to found a new bakery, while King took over
the Tennessee shop, which he renamed King’s
Bakery.
McKee’s official history leaves a giant
gap between 1936 and 1952.
However, it seems each bakery operated with
moderate success, though with little known
about them other than that it was during this
period that O.D. invented what is today the
company’s oldest continuously sold product-
the oatmeal creme pie.
By the mid-20th century, O.D. and his wife
decided to sell their bakery and reportedly
mulled over retiring, but at the request of
Ruth’s brother, Cecil, who at this point
was running King’s Bakery, returned to help
out managing it.
Rather than run someone else’s company for
them, not long after, O.D. and Ruth decided
to buy the bakery back and rename it McKee
Baking Company.
The company quickly flourished under their
management, which included the then innovative
idea to sell their product in “family packs”-
individually wrapped baked goods sold as a
package deal.
Specifically, in the late 1950s, McKee Foods
began producing “family packs” of 12 individually
wrapped cakes in one unit.
Thanks to essentially selling them in bulk
to customers, it allowed the company to drop
the price per unit slightly, while enjoying
a significant boost in product sales at the
same time.
According to Jack McKee (one of the couple’s
sons), most other snack companies didn’t
begin packaging items this way for another
decade or two.
This all brings us to how a straw hat clad
smiling girl named Debbie ended up on the
front of the boxes of mini treats.
There are slightly conflicting stories on
how O.D. came up with the idea to use “Little
Debbie,” but the general tale goes that
a packaging salesman, Bob Mosher, told O.D.
that the McKee name was boring and that he
needed something better to juice sales.
Casting about, O.D. supposedly noticed a picture
of his granddaughter, Debbie (daughter of
his son Ellsworth and daughter-in-law Sharon
McKee), on his desk and a light bulb went
off in his head.
Still wanting to use a family name, O.D. decided
on naming the company’s new line after Debbie
and to use the picture on his desk of her
in a straw hat as a logo.
Whether that’s exactly how he came up with
the idea or not, we do know definitively that
he had said picture in his office and that,
after inspiration struck, he didn’t tell
Debbie’s parents before going through with
final printing.
Not long after, famed pin-up artist Pearl
Frush Mann used that picture off of O.D.’s
desk to create a colored rendition of the
little girl that still graces boxes to this
day.
McKee Foods is still family-owned by second
and third generation McKees.
As for “Little Debbie,” Debbie McKee-Fowler,
she’s now all grown up and is the current
Executive Vice President of the company and
runs the “Little Debbie” brand.
While other snack cake companies may be struggling,
McKee Foods keeps thriving.
In 2015, they announced an over hundred million
dollars investment in their Collegedale factory.
In addition, they recently acquired Drake’s
cakes – who make Devil Dogs and Yodels – for
$27.5 million from bankrupt Hostess.